[موسيقى]
احييكم مشاهدينا واهلا بكم انا ميسون وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
جوانبه نبدا بالعناوين
الجيش منارش
جدلوا ق
ذائف
الابج في مصافحه الوداع تشيد تعهد لبوتين
بتغيير عالم جمد لمئه عام وطالبه بتوخي
الحذر وارسو تحذر من تحالفهما
ترامب يربح يوما جديدا مع تاجيل اجتماعي
لجنه المحلفين والجارديان تروج لمفاجاه
الرئيس السابق يريد الاصفاد
لدينا ايضا
الفيدرالي الامريكيه يرفع الفائده ربع
نقطه مئويه ويتعهد بخفض التضخم الى اثنين
بالمئه وحمايه الودائع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم انفجر جدلوا قذائف اليورانيوم
والمستنفذ حتى قبل ان تصل القذائف الى
وزير الخارجيه
ان القرار البريطاني بتزويد اوكرانيا بهذا
النوع يساعد الموقف الى مستويات خطيره وان
العواقب ستكون وخيمه
[موسيقى]
هذه خطوه نحو مزيد من التصعيد نحو تصعيد
خطير وكمي وصدرت تصريحات لبعض المسؤولين
الغربيين يقولون فيها انه لا يوجد شيء
مخيف في ذلك وان قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم
لم تكن محظوره وانهم لا يخالفون اي
اتفاقيات لكن الجميع يتذكرون نتائج
استخدام قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم في
يوغوسلافيا والعراق عندما اصيب عشرات
الالاف من المدنيين وجنود الناتو الذين
استخدموا قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم تلك
وفي لهجه اكثر حده كانت المتحدثه باسم
الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا اعتبرت ان خطط
بريطانيا لنقل قذائف اليورينيوم المستنفذ
الى كاذب هي استفزاز طائش اخر من قبل لندن
شددت خروف على ان لندن تساعد الصراع في
اوكرانيا الى مرحله جديده وتؤكد
نيه الغرب الجماعيه في تدمير اوكرانيا
مؤكده ان استخدام قذائف اليورينيوم يعد
مظهرا من مظاهر الاباده الجماعيه ضد
السكان
الرئيس البيلاروسي الكسندر لوكاتشينكو دخل
على خط الجدل الدائر وقال انه في حال قامت
لندن بتزويد كاف بقذائف من اليورانيوم
والمستنفذ فان موسكو لن تتاخر في تزويد
بلاده بقذائف تحتوي على يورانيوم حقيقي
اكد وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس كليفر
هي ان تزويده
والمستنفذ ليس تصعيدا نوويا كما تقول
روسيا واشار الى ان الدوله الوحيده التي
تتحدث عن قصائد النووي وتسعى اليه هي
روسيا
من القاهره ينضم الى اللواء سمير فرج
المحلل العسكريه لواء اهلا بكم معنا ما هو
تقييمكم لهذا التصعيد بين روسيا والغرب
بخصوص هذا اليورينيوم
المستنفذ هل من الممكن ان ينقل الحرب الى
مستوى ليس هناك يعني الى مستوى جديد
مساء الخير لحضرتك وكل الساده المشاهدين
انا بعتبر ان التصعيد جديد في اعمال
القتال على الجبلانيه اسمحيني في البدايه
نقول لهم امال ايه بقى تصعيد الفتره اللي
فاتت احنا كنا في فتره الشتاء وكانت
القوات الروسيه بتستخدم او بتنفذ عمليات
دفاعيه على الخطوط اللي وصلت لها وكانت
تستعد للهجوم في الربيع القادم بهجوم شامل
وطبعا هتستخدم فيه الدبابات على الطرف
الاخر اوكرانيا بدات تقول هتنفذ هجمات
مضاده عشان تستعيد الاراضي اللي فقدتها
وكمان هتستعد لصد الهجوم الروسي فوجئنا
طبعا النهارده بهذا التصعيد بوجود ذخائر
اليورانيوم المخصبه الذخائر دي بتستخدم ضد
الدبابات اساسا والمركبات المدرعه الارمر
اذا خائر دي بتيجي تخش في جسم الدبابه
بتعمل نافوره من النيران تدخل جوه الدبابه
تنفجر فيها اليور انيوم فبياثر على طقم
الدبابه حضره اللواء ساعود الى هذا
الموضوع لانه نحن لدينا شرح عن هذا
اليورينيوم ولكن بدايه نريد ان نفهم اذا
كانت الحرب ستنتقل الى مستوى جديد قبل ان
نتحدث عن
خاصيه هذه القذائف
اه طبعا هتنتقل لمستوى جديد واسمحيلي لسه
من خمس دقايق وزير الدفاع الروسي اتكلم
شويجي وقال انه هذا الموضوع سيؤدي الى
تصادم نووي وده اصطلاح جديد ما قالش حرب
نوويه تصادم نووي يعني هنا هتدي الفرصه
للروس ان هو يستخدم القنابل التكتيكيه
النوويه وده هيبقى تصاعد جديد وانت عارفه
قبل كده احنا طول الفتره اللي فاتت روسيا
بتهدد بالاستخدام النووي فعشان كده انا
شايف انه ده تصاعد جديد خاصه ان الموضوع
ده مش هيبقى مؤثر ولكن هي بتستخدمه ليه
لان هذه الذكاء لازم تستخدم من
اسلحه او من مدافع بريطانيه ما اقدرش
استخدمها على المدافع الروسيه اللي عند
اوكرانيا
لماذا لم تمنع مثلا هذه الذخائر لماذا
يسمح باستخدامها اصلا
هي هي اصلها لم تقنط لانها ليست سلاح نووي
هي فيها التخصيب اليورانيوم اللي بيصيب
الشخص داخل يعني زي نقول غازات الدم
والاعصاب هي ليست سلاح نووي ولكن تؤثر على
بتاعه الانسان فهي نفسها بالظبط بتخش على
طاقم الدبابه بتاثر على الرئه وعلى العظام
فعشان كده حتى الان هي مستخدمه ومسموح بها
دوليا ولكن هي عملت مشاكل في يغوسلافيا
وفي العراق واصابت كلا الطرفين ايضا لو
الروس ضربوا هذه القنابل قبل ان تستخدم
هتبقى مشكله على القوات الاوكرانيه فهي
سلاح للاسف لم يحرم ولكنه هيسبب مشاكل كده
الطرفين لواء فارس اسمح لي ان نتحدث عن
الفرق بين القذائف العاديه واليورينيوم
المستنفذ ومن ثم اعود لمتابعه الحديث معك
اذا مشاهدينا تحدثنا عن اليونانيوم
المستنفذ والانباء عن ارسال قذائف تحتوي
عليه لاوكرانيا لكن ما الفرق بين هذه
القذائف والقذائف التقليديه الاخيره
التقليديه يكون الراس المتفجر لها مليئا
بمواد شديده الانفجار مهما اختلف هدف
القذيفه اكان بهدف التفجير ام الاختراق
والتفجير من الداخل اما اليورانيوم
المستنفذ سيستخدم في تصنيع الذخيره
المضاده للدروع التي تطلق من الدبابات
والطائرات قذائف اليورينيوم المستنفذ يتم
استخدامها بطريقتين الاولى كيمياويه عبر
استعمال ما تسمى بالحشوه الجفاء
وتعني تفريغ راس المقذوف من المواد شديده
الانفجار الا من كميه صغيره من اليورينيوم
المستاندف يوضع امامها مخروط من النحاس
قبل ان يلمس المقدوف درع الدبابه تنفجر
شحنه المتفجرات ويتحول
النحاس الى تيار سريع ساخن من النحاس
المنصهر الذي يذيب الدرع وايضا يخترقه هذه
العمليه تعتمد على توليد طاقه ضغط وحراره
كافيه لاعطاب الهدف واختراقه وايضا تدميره
اما الاسلوب الاخر المستعمل في قذائف
اليورينيوم المستنفذ ميكانيكي يستخدم طاقه
الحركه للتدمير كيف يقوم على الاصطدام
المباشر مع الهدف واختراقه يقوم بتحطيم
اجزائه الحيويه من الداخل في هذه الحاله
تتم زياده سرعه المقذوف وكتلته وقدرته على
التماسك ليستطيع اتمام رحلته داخل الدرع
بنجاح من خلال زياده كميه اليورينيوم
المستنفذ كماده قادره على النفاذ عبر
الدروع لكن ماذا عن الاثار الصحيه لهذه
القذائف وهذا امر مهم في حاله اليورانيوم
المستنفذ لا تستطيع الاشعاعات الصادره منه
اختراق جلد الانسان لكن الضرر يحدث عند
وصول الماده الى داخل الجسم عن طريق
الاستنشاق او بلع مواد ملوثه
وهنا وصول الماده هذه لداخل الجسم يمكن ان
يزيد بثلاثه اضعاف احتمال الاصابه
بسرطانات الرئه والدم وغيرها كما ان
اليورانيوم يبقى مستقرا في الرئتين وفي
العظام ايضا حتى بعد الوفاه الان ساعود
الى ضيفنا من القاهره اللواء سمير فرج
لنتابع معه ايضا عن هذا الفرق بين القذيفه
التقليديه وقذيفه اليورينيوم المستنفذ
ارجو اولا لواء ان نكون قد شرحنا بطريقه
يعني يستطيع المشاهد ان يفهمها من دون
تعقيدات ولكن نريد منك ايضا ان نفهم علميه
جميله تسلم نريد منك ان نفهم
اعذرني نريد ان نفهم هل المخاوف لدى روسيا
هي عسكريه على دباباتها لانك كنت قلت قبل
ان نتوقف مع هذا التقرير بانه هذه القنابل
تفجر الدبابه يعني ليس من الصعب اصلاحها
هل هذه مخاوف روسيا اكثر من المخاوف بان
تضر الانسان
الاتنين مع بعض اولا زي ما شرحنا في
البدايه ان روسيا تبدا في الربيع القادم
الهجومي الشامل على اوكرانيا والهجوم
هيبدا بالدبابات وانت جايبه النهارده سلاح
جديد ضد الدبابات الروسيه فبالتالي دي
هتاثر تاثير مباشر على الدبابات التي
ستقوم بالهجوم المضاد الحاجه التانيه
هتاثر طبعا على الانسان وعلى الجند الروسي
هذه الطلقه بتدخل جوه الدبابه وتميت الطقم
داخلها يعني الذكر العاديه اللي انتم
قلتوها في البدايه بتصيب الدبابه وتعطلها
انت النهارده لا انت بتصيبي الدبابه
وتعطلها وتدخل الذخيره
اليونانيوم داخل الدبابه وتصيب الافراد زي
ما احنا قلنا في الرئه وفي العظام وتؤدي
الى السرطان فاكلا الطرفين بيؤدوا الى
التدمير عشان كده هذا السلاح اعتقد انه
هيضيق روسيا ومش
استخدام اليورانيوم المنظم والقانون
الدولي لا توجد اتفاقيه دوليه تحضر صراحه
استخدام سلاح اليورونيوم المنظم يمكن
تطبيق عده قوانين على استخدام هذا النوع
من السلاح اتفاقيه لها الماده الثانيه
والعشرون ليس للمتحاربين حق مطلق في
اختيار وسائل الاضرار بالعدو
اتفاقيه لهايا الماده الثالثه والعشرون
منع استخدام السم او الاسلحه السامه ملحق
اتفاقيه جنيف الماده الخام
منع استعمال اساليب القتال المسببه لاضرار
بالغه على البشر والبيئه
الرئيس الاوكرانيه في مواقع عسكريه للجيش
بالقرب من بلده بخمه الواقعه على خط
المواجهه مع القوات الروسيه في شرق
اوكرانيا والتي تعد مسرحا لاطول المعارك
بين كيافو موسكو منذ بدء الحرب في
اوكرانيا
هذا وقال البنك الدولي ان اوكرانيا تحتاج
الى 411 مليار دولار لاعاده الاعمار
التقييم الذي شارك فيه البنك الدولي
وحكومه اوكرانيا والمفوضيه الاوروبيه
والامم المتحده اشار الى ان كاف ستحتاج
الى 14 مليار دولار لاعاده الاعمار هذا
العام
المشاهدين سنتحدث عن هذه الازمه
الاقتصاديه في اوكرانيا بالطبع لها اكثر
من وجهها لكن ازمه الحبوب يمكن اختصارها
في شركه عملاقه لهذه الصناعه تدهورت فيها
الامور بحسب تقرير لصحيفه فاينانشل تايمز
البريطانيه الصحيفه قالت ان شركه نبيولون
تراجعت اوضاعها بسبب الحرب بعدما كانت
احدى اكبر شركات الصناعات الزراعيه في
اوكرانيا وفي العالم من مدينه نيكولايف
انطلقت الشركه لحمل ملايين الاطنان من
الحبوب في ناقلات متجهه الى الاسواق
العالميه هذه الشركه كانت جزءا من اعاده
تشكيل اوكرانيا ما بعد الاتحاد السوفيتي
التي اطلق عليها سله خبز العالم القطاع
الزراعي في اوكرانيا كان جزءا مهما من
الاقتصاد الاوكراني مع وجود 14% من السكان
في القطاع الذي يمثل ثلث الناتج المحلي في
اوكرانيا وبعد ان كانت مصدرا لعشرين مليون
طن في الحبوب سنويا ساهمت الشركه بمضاعفه
المحصول ثلاث مرات عام
2021 ومنذ بدء الحرب كان على نبيولان
التكيف مع عدم التصدير من البحر الاسود
وايضا ارتفاع تكاليف النقل ما ادى لانخفاض
الصادرات من مقدار الثلثين خلال العام
الماضي قبل الحرب كان لدى الشركه سته الاف
موظف اما اليوم اربعون بالمئه من موظفيها
لا يستطيعون العمل بسبب التحاقهم بالجيش
او لسكنهم في اراد خاضعه حاليا للسيطره
الروسيه
اهميه هذه الشركه محليا وعالميا وضعت
مؤسسها اوليكسي
على لائحه المستهدفين من قبل روسيا بحسب
ما تقول اوكرانيا ليلقى مصرعه في يوليو
الماضي في قصف على نيكولايف
[موسيقى]
رغم انتهاء زياده الرئيس الصيني لروسيا
لكن كواليسها ما تزال تثير الكثير من
التفاعلات مواقع التواصل ضجه بفيديو لحديث
جانبي بين
بوتينغ قبيله مغادره الاخير للكرملين بدا
وكانه وصيه ووعد من حليف لحليفه
التغيير قادم ولم يحدث منذ 100 عام ونحن
نقود هذا التغيير معا
من فضلك اعتني بنفسك يا صديقي العزيز
اتمنى لك رحله امنه
زياره الرئيس السنين شهدت ابتعاده عن
الفنادق الفاخره المحيطه بالميدان الاحمر
في موسكو واختياره جناحا رئاسيا في فندق
المملوك للصين يقع فندق سولوكس داخل مركز
اعمال صينيا ضخم بمساحه 12 فدانا وافتتح
العمل الماضي بعد تغيير الملكيه وتعتبر بل
تعتبر دولتان الفندقات تجسيدا للعلاقات
الصينيه الروسيه التي طوطت بشكل كبير منذ
بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا وسائل اعلام
روسيه اشارت الى ان سلسله شركه سوليوكس
الصينيه اصبحت مالكه الفندق بعد خروج
مجموعه انتركو من روسيا الى جانب العديد
من الشركات الاخرى المملوكه للغرب الجناح
الرئاسي لتشيي مكون من سبع غرف ويقع في
الطابق العشرين وتبلغ مساحته 4000 قدم
مربع وادى وجود الرئيس الصيني في المنطقه
لاغلاق عده طرق حيويه تربط موسكو بضواحيها
الشماليه الشرقيه حيث يقع الفندق
الزياره شهدت كذلك دخولا الامريكيه على
الخط لكنه ليس دخولا دبلوماسيا وانما
دخولا لاكياس من الواجبات بلوجبات السريعه
الامريكيه لمصلحه الوفد الصيني بحسب ما
تداولت فيه وسائل اعلاما غربيه
[موسيقى]
حتى المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه
واشنطن على توقف عن القاء اللومه في
القضيه الاوكرانيه مؤكدا انها ستواصل
دورها لايجاد حل سياسي
[موسيقى]
نحث الولايات المتحده على دراسه دورها في
القضيه الاوكرانيه وتصحيح سلوكها الخاطئ
المتمثل في صب الزيت على النار والتوقف عن
القاء اللوم على الصين سنواصل الوقوف بحزم
الى جانب السلام والحوار والصواب التاريخي
والعمل بشكل بناء مع المجتمع الدولي
لمواصله دورنا في تعزيز حل سياسي للقضيه
الاوكرانيه
وكان وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انتوني
بلينكن قال ان دعم الصين السياسي والمادي
لروسيا يتعارض مع مصالح واشنطن مضيفا ان
الصين لم تتجاوز بعد الخط الاحمر
لتسليم روسيا اسلحه فتاكا وقال ان رد فعل
الغرب على الحرب الروسيه يجب ان يكون
بمثابه درس للصين
الصوت الاوروبي الاكثر صخبا في الاونه
الاخيره اعتبرت المحور الروسي الصيني
خطيرا
زياره رئيس الصيني لموسكو زادت من حده
القلق الحاصل هذا المحور بين الصين وروسيا
خطيره نحاول اقناع الصين بعدم دعم روسيا
في سياستها الدوليه العدوانيه هناك نظام
جيوسياسي جديد يظهر امام اعيننا واصبح امن
اليابان وبولندا فجاه ظاهره يجب مناقشتها
في وقت واحد فيما يتعلق بالتهديدات التي
تتعرض لها اسيا واوروبا
في العربيه 360 نسبب بعد لحظات
مع تواصل الاحتجاجات على قانون التقاعد
يقول انه على استعدادا لخساره شعبيته من
اجل فرنسا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في الولايات المتحده
افادتنيز بان هيئه المحلفين الخاصه بقضيه
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
نيويورك لن تجتمع اليوم الاربعاء وذلك
لسماع الادله بخصوص دفع ترامب 130 الف
دولار قبل اسبوعين من انتخابات الرئاسه
عام 2016
للممثله ستورميدان لشراء صمتها حول علاقه
بينهما قبل ذلك قالت ترامب انه قد لا
يواجه لائحه اتهام بشان قضيه دفعه اموالا
لممثله افلام اباحيه لشراء صمتها عن علاقه
جمعتهما لكن المتحدث باسم ترامب قال ان
الاخيره لم يخطر رسميا بعد بايتها وان
تصريحاته تعتمد على تقارير اعلاميه
قالت مصادر لصحيفه جارديان البريطانيه ان
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
يوريتو تقييد يديه للمثول امام المحكمه في
منهاتن في نيويورك بحسب الصحيفه اشارت
ترامبلي مستشاريه ان تقييد يديه خلف ظهره
ياتي لدوافع مختلفه منها تحدي ما يراه
محاكمه غير عادله اضافه لتحفيز قاعدته
الانتخابيه قبل رئاسيات العام المقبل
واضافت المصادر ان رغبه ترامب قد لا تتم
بسبب قواعد جهاز الخدمه السريه للرؤساء
الحاليين والسابقين للولايات المتحده
المدعي العامي مقاطعه بالم بيتش في ولايه
فلوريدا التي يقطن فيها ترامب كان اعلن ان
جهاز الخدمه السريه لن يسمح بتكميل يديه
ترامبرج توقع ان يسافر ترامب الى نيويورك
لتسليم نفسه على ان يتم اخذ بصمات اصابعه
ثم اطلاق سراحه دون كفاله ماليه
مباشره من امام محكمه الجنايات في منهات
جنوب نيويورك مراسل العربيه حسين اهلا بك
معنا ما هي ابرز تطورات مثلا تاجيل اجتماع
لجنه المحلفين هل يمكن اعتباره بانه امر
طبيعي ام هناك شيء ما يطبخ في الكواليس
تحيه لك ميسون يمكن ان تعيد الصوت هناك
تشويش حصل الان لا اعرف
تعيد السؤال
كنا نقول تاجيل اجتماع لجنه المحلفين
اليوم هل هو امر طبيعي مثلا ام هناك شيء
يطبخ في الكواليس
[تصفيق]
حتى الان لا تعرف الاسباب التي دعت الى
تاجيل اجتماع هيئه المحلفين الكبرى اليوم
ولكن مدعي عام من هاتن طلب من اعضاء هذه
الهيئه ان يكونوا جاهزين للاجتماع غدا
هذه الهيئه ميسون تعمل بسريه كان من
المفترض ان تجتمع اليوم وكان من المتوقع
ان يطلب منها المحققون
من اعضائها ان يصوتوا على
توجيه توم التراب ام لا هي تتالف من 23
عظم بالمناسبه يكفي ان يصوت على توجيها
الاتهام اثنا عشر عضوا ولكن كما قلنا لا
تعرف الاسباب لانها تعمل بالسريه مطلقه
حتى اننا لا نعرف بعد كم عدد
الشهود الذين ستستمع اليهم حتى تنهي عملها
وتقدم الملف للمدعي العام ولكن على موقع
التواصل الاجتماعي الخاص به
اشار الى نقطه مهمه قال بان المحامي روبرت
كوستيو الذي كان يعمل مستشارا قانونيا
ومحاميا لمحاميه السابق مايكل يبدو انه
قدم ادله قويه وهذا ما كان صرح به بانه
لديه ادله تبرئ ترامب من اي تهم يبدو انه
قدم هذه الادله كما اشار ترامب واشار
ترامب ايضا الى وجود خلاف بين المدعي
العام لمن هات
وبين اعضاء هيئه المحلفين لذلك هو يتوقع
ان يتم توجيه تهم اليه
هناك قضيه عندها تجري اليوم جرت اليوم
منها هذا التاجيل وايضا لسنا لا نعرف
بالضبط اذا كانت ستجتمع غدا
لتصوت وحتى اذا اجتمعت ليس من المؤكد انهم
سيصوتون هناك العديد من المصادر تقول بان
اجتماعها لا يعني التصويت ولا يعني توجيه
تهم لترامب وقد يتاجل الموضوع الى الاسبوع
المقبل ليتم تحديد ذلك
شكرا لك من امام محكمه الجنايات في منهات
جنوب نيويورك مراسل العربيه حسين الطوضع
على هذه التفاصيل
المسار الذي يواجهه ترامب مسار غير معهود
لرئيس امريكي فهو يواجهه عقبات قضائيه لا
تنتهي في الوقت الذي ترتفع فيه فم
الانتخابات الرئاسيه نتابع
[موسيقى]
قضيه واحده اعادت فتح 4000 قضيه اخرى
دونالد ترامب الرئيس الذي غادر المنصب ولم
يختفي من المشهد الاعلامي بعد اتهام ترامب
الرئيس ترامب رجل الاعمال جاء دور ترامب
المترشح ليدخل المحاكم القضيه تعود الى
عام 2016 حين اتهمت ممثله اباحيه ترامب
بشراء صمتها خوفا من فضيحه تعكر حملته
الانتخابيه القضيه كانت اقرب الى مجرد
تسويه شخصيه الا ان شهاده صديق سابق جاءت
لتغير مسار التحقيق ميشال كوهين محامي
ترامب السابق اعترف بانه دفع شخصيا 130
الف دولار لتسويه القضيه من اموال حمله
موكله الانتخابيه ترامب لا يواجه التهمه
للمره الاولى الا انه سيقف هذه المره امام
محكمه نيويورك التي يسيطر عليها مدعي عام
الديمقراطي حتى النخ القضيه احيت قضايا
سابقه ومعها جدوى رئيس لا تنقصه المشاكل
بعضها تم تصنيفها كتهم جنائيه وتكفي ادانه
واحده لتنسفه طموحاته السياسيه
بايادي مكبله قد يقف اول رئيس امريكي امام
محكمه جنائيه الا ان سمعه رئيس سابق لا
تهم ترامب وانصاره بقدر سمعه مترشح
للانتخابات المقبله
اتهمت ديمقراطيين باستغلال النفوذ لتسييس
القضيه وهي الحجه التي استغلها للاعب
ورقته المفضله المتمثله بدعوه الانصار
للاعتصام انصار الحزب الجمهوري وان لم يعد
ترامب يحظى بالاجماع بينهم الا انهم
اعتبروه نفقا مظلما عبور ترامب منه بسلام
سيقوده الى البيت الابيض من الباب الواسع
من واشنطن ينضم اليه الباحثون الامريكيه
والعلاقات الدوليه ايهاب عباس استاذ ايهاب
اهلا بكم معنا يبدو بان الرئيس ترامباني
حسب الجاردن بانه يريد تقييد يديه يبدو
بانه يريد ان يخرج رابحا من هذه القضيه
ولكن السؤال هل هو قادر على ذلك وهل سيحصل
على مبتغى
نعم اهلا بحضرتك وبكل المشاهدين انا شخصيا
اعتقد ان الرئيس دونالد ترامب بالفعل هو
ربح الكثير من خلال ما يحدث اليوم
طبقا للبيانات التي خرجت من المدعي العام
في نيويورك كان من المفترض ان يمثل امامه
بالامس لكن هذا لم يحدث ولم يحدث اليوم
ايضا هذا دليل على ان هناك حاله من التردد
لدى النائب العام في نيويورك الذي هو ايضا
محسوب على الديمقراطيين بشكل كبير جدا
وهذا يضع علامه استفهام كبيره
بالاتهامات التي وجهها الرئيس دونالد
ترامب دائما لمثل هذا النوع من القضايا
بانها مسيسه وانها الغرض منها النيل منه
وتحقيق مكاسب سياسيه لمنافسيه تحديدا طبعا
الحزب الديمقراطي وبالفعل يعني اذا ما
شاهدنا ما حدث قبل ذلك في اغسطس العام
الماضي
والوثائق التي تم الكشف عنها في منتجع حيث
يعيش الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب والبلبل
الكبيره التي حول هذا الموضوع من انه
سيحاكم بتثريب بتسريب قضايا امن قومي
ووثائق سريه الى هذا هو
السؤال ايهاب يعني هناك عده قضايا يعني
اذا بريئه من هذه القضيه هناك ايضا قضيه
الكابيتال هناك ايضا قضيه التهرب من
الضرائب هناك عده قضايا هل سيستمر مسلسل
القضايا حتى الانتخابات الرئاسيه حتى يقطع
الطريق عليه ان يترشح او ان يفوز بترشح
الجمهوريين
سيستمر ولكن للاسف تاتي بنتائج عكسيه طبقا
لما يعتقده الديمقراطيون او منافسه الرئيس
دونالد ترامب لماذا لان اليوم شعبيه الرجل
في صعود مستمر وهناك كره ثلج بدات تكبر
لمصلحته شاهدنا الانتخابات التي اجريت في
الحزب الجمهوري قبل سبع قليله جدا للجناح
المحافظ وفاز بها الرئيس دونالد ترامب
باكثر من 64% قدرات ترامب على حشد الشارع
الامريكي وقدراته في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الماضيه هو لم يكسر نذكر بفرق مثلا عشره
ملايين صوت خسر بفارق بفارق مئات الالاف
من الاصوات استطاع ان يحشد ما يخرج من 67
مليون صوت تقريبا 48% من اصوات الناخبين
الامريكيين واليوم بالرغم من انه
الانتخابيه بشكل مبسط الا انه اليوم يحقق
زخما كبيرا لدى الناخب الامريكي خاصه انه
لا توجد اتهامات واضحه حتى الان وعدم قدره
على ادانته في اي من الملفات التي ذكرناها
قبل ان اتابع استاذ ايهاب ايضا نذكر
بالاخبار عاجله ايضا وارده من الولايات
المتحده وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه تقول ما
حدث مع بنك سيليكون فالي قد يتكرر مع بنوك
اخرى في المستقبل اذا هناك تحذيرات من
وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه بانه ما حصل مع
سيليكون فاليسيتكرر او قد يتكرر مع بنوك
اخرى في المستقبل اسمح لي ان تبقى معي
لنتحدث عن ما قاله بولتن في لقاء مع
تيليجراف قال مستشار الامن القومي السابق
جون بولتون انه يجب على الحزب الجمهوري ان
ينظف نفسه من الضرر الذي تسبب به دونالد
ترامب للحزب
لا اعلم ماذا سيكون رد ترامب لكن بعض من
القاده الجمهوريين يقولون انه لا يجب على
الناس التظاهر لصالحه اظن انه لا حدود لما
يمكن ان يفعله ترامب ويجب ان نقلق من ذلك
يجب على الحزب الجمهوري ان ينظف نفسه من
الضرر الذي تسبب به ترامب وهذه مسؤوليتنا
كجمهوريين
مره جديده اليك عباس البحث الشؤون
الامريكيه والعلاقات الدوليه هذا التصريح
اليوم
يعني تغير المواقف من حلفاء الامس الى هذه
التصريحات اليوم ايضا دسنتوس بالامس كان
ايضا شكك بهذه القضيه حول الرئيس ترامب
هذه المواقف هذا الجدل حول مواقف من هم
يعني محيطين بالترامب ان كان منافسه لسانه
او حتى بلطيم هل يستمع الناس الى ارائهم
هل ستؤثر هذه الاراء من اشخاص مثل
البولتون ودسنتوس على شعبيه ترامب
من الممكن ان تؤثر طبعا لكن ما نشاهده
اليوم داخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هو
ازدياد لشعبيه الرئيس دونالد ترامب في
اوساط الامريكيين الذين من الممكن ان يطلق
عليهم الطبقه الوسطى والطبقه ما تحت
الوسطى او ما دون الوسطى لماذا لان
الاصلاحات الاقتصاديه التي اتى بها الرئيس
دونالد ترامب خلال السنوات الاربع التي
حكم فيها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كانت
ملموسه وملحوظه فقط مشكلته كانت في
التعامل مع وباء كورونا عندما استخف به
واستغل ذلك الحزب الديمقراطي وحقق بعد ذلك
الانتصار في الانتخابات الرئاسيه لكن
ترامب استطاع ان يرفع اسهم البورصات
الامريكيه ومعدلات نقاط الاسهم باكثر من
25 الف نقطه واستطاع ان يبرم اتفاقيات
التجاريه قويه جدا مع الصين تعيد الحقوق
الامريكيه المنهوبه من قبل الصين ولكن
للاسف لم تطبق لانه لم يعطى الفرصه طبعا
لانه دخل بعد ذلك في دوامه كورونا ومن ثم
الخروج من البيت الابيض بعد الانتخابات
التي خسرها بالاضافه الى انه استطاع
ان متوفره في او الامريكيين من اصول
افريقيه تفوق الاعداد التي حققها اي رئيس
سابق وبالتالي حقق الكثير للولايات
المتحده الامريكيون اليوم بسبب المعاناه
التي تفرضها اداره جو بايدن بسبب العقوبات
المفروضه على روسيا واثارها السلبيه وعدم
قدره لانفدرالي الامريكي ولا وزيره
الخزانه الامريكيه جانتيا ولا الحكومه
الامريكيه مجتمعه القضاء على التضخم كلها
تشير الى ان الامريكيين بشكل كبير اليوم
من الممكن ان يعطوا الرئيس دونالد ترامب
فرصه اخرى للترشح للانتخابات بل والفوز
واقول لحضرتك سريعا ترامب يستطيع ان يحكم
الولايات المتحده حتى لو كان في السجن
بالمناسبه طبقا للقانون الامريكي شكرا لك
من واشنطن على البحث
على المشاركه معنا في العربيه 360
[موسيقى]
الى فرنسا الان حيث شدد الرئيس الفرنسي
عشيه تصعيد المحتجين على تمرير قانون
التقاعد على ضروره ان يدخل القانون حيز
التنفيذ هذا العام وقال ماكرون ان قانون
اصلاح التقاعد ضروري لانقاذ النظام باكمله
مؤكدا انه لا يمكن قبول التمرد في الشارع
ضد قانون التقاعد وسيتم العمل على عوده
الوضع الى طبيعته في البلاد باسرع وقت كما
اضاف الرئيس الفرنسي ان القانون لا يعجبه
شخصيا لكنه من اجل المصلحه العامه
الاكثر من ذلك مكون قال انه مستعد لتحمل
خساره شعبيته ان كانت هي الثمن لتمرير
الاصلاحات
اقول لكم بمسؤوليه انا لا اتطلع الى اعاده
انتخابي لا يمكنني دستوريا لكن بين
استطلاعات الراي والمدى القصير والمصلحه
العامه للبلاد اختار المصلحه العامه
للبلاد واذا كان من الضروري تحمل ان اخسر
الشعبيه اليوم فسوف اتحملها
وكانت الاداره العامه للطيران المدني في
فرنسا طلبت من شركات الطيران الغاء 30% من
رحلتها المقرره الخميس في مطار باريس
وعشرين بالمئه في المطارات الاخرى بسبب
اضراب مراقب الحركه الجويه وتوقعت الاداره
والغاء واحده من بين كل خمس رحلات اقلاع
او هبوط غدا
من ناحيه اخرى منعت الشرطه مسيره طلابيه
مناهضه لقانون التقاعد الجديد من الوصول
الى جامعه بيار وماري كوري وسط باريس
وانطلق مئات الطلبه والمدرسين في مسيره من
امامي وزاره التعليم العالي قبل ان
تواجههم الشرطه وتمنعهم من الالتقاء
بمسيرات اخرى
[موسيقى]
في تركيا ومع اقتراب موعد الانتخابات بدا
الشكل النهائي للتحالفات السياسيه يتضح
اكثر فاكثر وفي جديد التحالفات حزب مؤيد
للاكراد يقرر دعم مرشح المعارضه الرئيسيه
واردوغان يفشل في استماله احد وزرائه
السابقين
في خطوه متوقعه اعلنت تحالف العمل والحريه
المعارض في تركيا عدم طرح اي مرشح رئاسي
في الانتخابات القادمه ما يعني دعما لمرشح
المعارضه الرئيسي كمال كيلج داروجلو
اجرينا عمليه تقييم شامله لاعلان مرشح من
طرفنا في تحالف الحريه والعمل حيث كنا قد
اعلنا سابقا اننا سنسمي مرشحا لرئاسه بعد
تقييم الشامل نعلن رسميا باننا لن نقدم
مرشحا باسم التحالف لخوض الانتخابات
الرئاسيه القادمه وسنتحمل مسؤوليتنا
التاريخيه في مواجهه نظام حكم الرجل
الواحد القائم حاليا
التحالف الذي يقوده حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي
المؤيد للاكراد اتخذ هذا القرار بعد
اجتماع قياده الحزب الكردي مع كيلج دار
اوكلو الاثنين الماضي حيث يسعى زعيم
المعارضه لكسب دعم ناخبين الاكراد كممثل
عن تحالف الامه المعارض او ما بات يعرف
باسم الطاوله السداسيه هذا التحالف تقدم
بدوره رسميا الى المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات
بطلب ترشيحك
ى جئنا الى المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات مع
الاعضاء المعقرين في تحالف الامه قدمنا
طلبه ترشيح الرئيس الثالث عشر للجمهوريه
التركيه كماركل شيدار اوغلو
في المعسكر المقابل تبدو مهمه الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان صعبه في الانتخابات القادمه
في ظل دعم جديد تلقاه كيليجار اوكلو وايضا
ما ذكره نائب رئيس الوزراء السابق محمد
شمشك عن رفضه الانخراط في اي منصب حكومي
مع حكومه اردوغان القادمه في حال فاز
الرئيس بالانتخابات
[تصفيق]
قال انه لن يستمر في العمل السياسي ليس له
تاثير محتمل في الانتخابات برايي من جانب
المعارضه خصوصا يوجد استقطاب كبير وهم
يرون انه الوقت الانسب لرحيل اردوغان
في ضوء المستجدات الراهنه يحاول تحالف
الشعب الذي يقوده اردوغان تعزيز تحالفه
وكسب فئات جديده لذلك تحالف مع حزب الدعوه
الحره المدعوم من الاكراد المحافظين لا شك
ان هذه الانتخابات تمثل مساله حياه او موت
للقطبين الرئيسيين فيها وهما اردوغان
وكليجدار اوكلو لذلك من المنتظر ان نشهد
في الايام القادمه مزيدا من التحركات تجاه
تيارات سياسيه كانت على الهامش يوما ما
بغيت جذب اصواتها لاحد المرشحين زيدان
زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول
في العربيه 360 كل شيء في لبنان اليوم
شحيح الا شيء واحد مؤذن
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد رفع البنك الاحتياطي
الفائده بربع نقطه مئويه لتصل الى 5% وهي
الاعلى منذ عام 2007 وجاء قرار الفيدرالي
متماشيا مع اغلب توقعات المحللين على
الرغم من مطالبات عده بوقف رفع اسعار
الفائده خاصه بعد ازمه تعثر ثلاثه بنوك
امريكيه الاسبوع الماضي واستبدل بيان
الفيدرالي عباره رفع مستمر للفائده
بتوقعات الاعضاء ان المزيد من التشديد في
السياسه النقديه قد يكون مناسبا للوصول
بالتضخم الى مستوى اثنين بالمئه وتعليقا
على الازمه الحاليه للبنوك اشهر البيان
الى ان القطاع المصرفي متين لكن الاحداث
الاخيره ممكن ان تؤدي الى تشديدا في شروط
الائتمان وتاثير سلبي على النمو الا ان
حجم التاثير لا يزال غير واضح
وبعد قرار الفيدرالي اكد رئيس الاحتياطي
الفيدرالي جيرون باول في المؤتمر الصحفي
على توجهات البنك بخفض معادلات التضخم الى
المستهدفات السابقه عند اثنين في المئه
ان معدلات التضخم ما زالت مرتفعه كثيرا
وسوق العمل ما زالت قويه اتفاهم وزملائي
اثار التضخم السيئه على الاغتصاد واريد ان
اؤكد اننا ملتزمون وبشده بخفض معدلات
التضخم الى مستهدفاتنا عند اثنين في المئه
ضمان استقرار الاسعار هو مسؤوليه
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي وبدون استقرار
الاسعار فان الاقتصاد لن يكون جيدا لاي
احد
من دبي ينضم الينا محرر الشؤون الاقتصاديه
في قناه العربيه زميل عباده عباده اهلا بك
معنا الخيارات كانت صعبه امام الفيدرالي
كل الخيارات ولكن هل رفع اسعار الفائده هو
تصريح وتاكيد من الفيدرالي بانه موضوع
التضخم اهم من موضوع النمو الاقتصادي اهم
الموضوع تعثر بعض البنوك في الولايات
المتحده
نعم بالفعل هو ارسل رساله واضح بانها
معركه التضخم لا يمكن ان يخسرها هذه معركه
اساسيه جدا بالنسبه له ولكن في نفس الوقت
ايضا هناك اعتبار اخر اخذه الاحتياطي
الفيدرالي في الاعتبار وهو انه اراد ان
يمشي مع توقعات السوق اراد ان لا يفاجئ
سوق لانه مفاجاه السوق في هذا الظرف
الدقيق جدا يعني في وقت الجميع يحاول ان
يتابع مدى تطور ازمه المصارف والى اين
يمكن ان تصل اي مفاجاه يمكن ان يكون لها
اثر سلبي جدا فبالتالي هو يعني ما قام به
هو نصف تراجع اذا تذكرنا فقط انه في قبل
اسبوعين كان يتحدث امام الكونجرس وقال
امام الكونجرس اعطى اشاره الى مزيد من
التشدد في ذلك الوقت
وفهم السوق حين انه ربما يرفع الفائده
باكثر اتت ازمه
كل ما هو مرتبط بها يعني التراجع نصف
تراجع يعني تراجع عن التشدد
الفائده لانه ما حصل مع سيليكون فالي معظم
المحللين يقولون بسبب رفع هذه الفائده
والان حتى يعني قبل قليل كان هناك خبر
عاجل على العربيه وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه
كانت حذرت من الممكن ان
يتعثر او تتعثر بعض البنوك في المستقبل هل
نحن امام مشهد تعثر بنوب في الولايات
المتحده بسبب هذه الفائده ورفعها
لا شك انه رفع الفائده بهذه الوتيره سريعه
جدا نتحدث عن 5% من صفر الى خمسه في المئه
في قدوم فتره يعني سنه وشهرين او سنه او
ثلاثه اشهر هذه الوتيره سريعه جدا من
الرفع لا شك انها اثرت على يعني او وضع
المالي في عدد من البنوك المتوسطه الحجم
والتي اضطرت الى بيع اصولها المشكله الان
هي كيف يتفاعل الجمهور مع هذه الازمه يعني
المساله الاساسيه هي السحوبات من البنوك
وماذا قدره البنوك عند تحمل هذا الامر
اليوم اعطى اشارتين اساسيتين الاولى فيما
يتعلق بتضخم والتي سبقت الاشاره اليها
والثانيه تتعلق بتاثير التطورات المصرفيه
على الاقتصاد قال بوضوح
سيكون هناك تاثير على التوظيف على الانشطه
الاقتصاديه على سوق الائتمان لكن يعني في
هناك عدم يقين حول مدى هذا التاثير
الاشاره المهمه الجمله المفتاحيه التي
قالها بانه هذه التطورات في قطاع المصرفي
ربما تؤدي الى تضييق سوق الائتمان او الى
تجديد سوق الاهتمام وهذا هو المفعول الذي
المرتجم رفع الفائده فبالتالي قد يعوض عن
رفع الفائده على كل حال عباده دعنا الان
ايضا ان ننتقل من الولايات المتحده الى
منطقتنا العربيه لانه ايضا هناك رفع
بالاسعار وساعود اليك بعد رفع الاحتياطي
الفيدرالي طبعا اسعار الفائده قرر البنك
المركزي السعودي سما رفع معدلات اعاده
الشراء ومعدلات اعاده الشراء العكسيه
بخمسه وعشرين نقطه اساس كما رفع البنك
المركزي القطري اسعار الفائده على الايداع
والاقراض ب 25 نقطه اساس البنك المركزي
البحرينيه ايضا قرار رفع اسعار الفائده
بربع نقطه مئويه ايضا
اعود مجددا الى زميلنا عباده لدى المحرر
الشؤون الاقتصاديه في قناه العربيه عباده
هذه القرارات للبنوك الخارجيه للبنوك
العربيه ايضا من المرتقب ان يكون هناك
ايضا بعض البنوك تعلن مثلا عن رفع هذه
الفائده كيف ستؤثر على الناس كيف ستؤثر
على عمليه الاقراض يعني الكل الاهم يتساءل
على موضوع اللغز والقروض اللي اخذينها
سترتفع الفائده كثيرا عليها طمنا عباده
ماذا سيحصل
بطبيعه الحال الرفع السريع للفائده العام
الماضي غير في حياه الكثير من الناس الذين
ترتبط فوائد قروضهم باسعار الفائده
الامريكيه لانه بطبيعه الحال كما نعرف
جميعا انه معظم العملات الخليجيه مرتبطه
بالدولار الامريكي فبالتالي لابد من رفع
الفائده في كل مره ترتفع فيها الفائده
الامريكيه الان الاشاره الجديده من
الاحتياط الفيدرالي انه
ربما ربما يعني الاسواق على الاقل فهمت
انه ربما يكون هذا الرفع
تاتي بعده استراحه نوعا ما
وبالتالي لذلك راينا ارتفاع الاسهم
الامريكيه وتراجع وقت سادات الخزينه
الامريكيه هذا قد يؤثر يعني في المنطقه
اذا كان هذا فعلا هذا الرفع سنرتاح بعده
لفتره من عمليات رفع الفائده ربما هذا
يعطي بعض الاستراحه للذين تلتقي عليهم
الفوائد وايضا هذا ينعكس بطبيعه الحال على
القروض الجديده ومساله اخرى انه رفع
الفائده السريع خلال العام الماضي اثر على
مستويات السيوله في القطاعات المصرفيه
الخليجيه وادى الى ارتفاع الفوائد المحليه
شكرا لك عباده لدى زميلنا في قناه العربيه
محرر الشؤون الاقتصاديه على كل هذه
التفاصيل والتوضيحات
[موسيقى]
في تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 مدعي عام
الجنائيه الدوليه ينفذ اوامر اسياده
الانجلوس ساكسونيين هذا الاتهام القاسي
صدر من وزير الخارجيه الروسي
بحق المدعي العام كريم احمد خان وازاد
عليه لافروف بالتاكيد على ان هؤلاء
الاسياد يمنعون المحكمه من التحقيق في
جرائم الدول الاعضاء
طبعا تصريحات تاتي بعد ان صدرت مذكره
توقيف بحق الرئيس بوتين
اما فيديو اليوم فهو من نيس الفرنسيه
المحتجون على اصلاح النظام التقاعد يغلقون
محطه القطار سلوكهم لا يبدو عنيفا يهتفون
ويغنون مع بعض الالعاب الناريه الصغيره
لكن رسائلهم حاده للغايه فهذه القطارات لن
تتحرك ولو تحركت فانها ستدهس وغريمهم
الاول ماكرون
[موسيقى]
سوره اليوم من بيروت يحاول الجندي تهدئه
روعه الصبي الصغير بعد ان استنشق الغاز
المسيل للدموع لا تقلق يا صغير كل شيء
سيكون على ما يرام الناس فقط غاضبه لان
لدينا شحف الدولار في الطعام في الدواء
لدينا شحف كل شيء اما هذه التي تطير هناك
فلدينا منها الكثير قنابل الغاز
العربيه
360 تنتهي الان ولكن اخبار العربيه دائما
مستمره والان الى اخبار الساعه والزميل
صهيب شراير صهيب مساء الخير ماذا لدينا
الليله مساء الخير ميسون طبعا قبلها
اعايدك واعيد المشاهدين بمناسبه حلول شهر
رمضان المباركه الخميس غرت الشهر الفضيل
في اغلب الدول العربيه
وسنبدا من الخطر النووي الذي باتى حقيقيا
هذه المره باعلان بريطانيا ارسال قذائف
تعمل باليورانيوم المستنفذ الى اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]